our faithful leader i don't know if he
understand knows this or not but he's
had me guest host this show
seven times this year seven seven times
it's a bromance it really is it's a
bromance a brother from another
uh rich eisen live from cleveland ohio
how you doing rich
how are you guys doing how are you gents
what up rich
hey we're having a blast i mean there's
it's uh it's really easy to
it's really easy to talk about uh um
talk about a lot of stuff today because
of the draft you were there
what was it like to kind of not only not
only
it was the draft but doing it again
right being in front of
a a an audience and all the things that
went down
last night it was great just amazing
just awesome it's now also stopped
raining so that makes it really
nice um hit literally just about an hour
ago
it started raining yesterday morning and
it just stopped now so it should be a
chilly but
uh clear night tonight for nights two
and three and
fans were were were hot thrilled i mean
brock would at one point it was turned
into like fenway park with sweet
caroline
i was watching it and it was really
funny uh you just bringing up song
lyrics the whole time after that
well i mean it was it's so loud i mean
and i know you're hearing it at home
it's kind of like my
the idea of you know i got to talk about
what people are hearing yeah
but the funny thing is is that you know
if they were just getting to the
sing-along part just as goodell got the
podium
and we were wondering like is the
commissioner going to tell him to stop
playing like sometimes
roger would look at the band like you
know
johnny carson coming back from break or
letterman would kind of like
make a hand movement to tell the band to
stop playing
rod you know the commissioner would do
that from time to time but
when when when everyone was screaming
you know so good like he kept he
he was he was like he got into it yeah
he was egging them
on and that was the general sense of the
room it was like a it was
giddy like everyone was kidding like
we're here like this is happening like
you know and we're we're getting closer
to normal and we're back and we're in
person
and it was you could feel the vibe and
it was great
and you know and then trades start
happening and
um it was you know and then and then
once you know matt jones went off the
board i'll i'll be honest
it it kind of um you know the night
began to wind down a little bit and then
the browns got on the clock 26th overall
the boos were lusty for the steelers
24th overall
it was it was it was just fun and i
think tonight's going to even be
better because it's not going to be
raining on top of people
yeah i mean weather can play a huge
factor and
poor cleveland had to live through it
last night joe thomas at the top of his
lungs to open the night i thought
was pretty great um you were at the
table 17th year you've done this you
were around all the guys
making their prognostications or
analyzing what just went down was there
was there something that that truly
shocked anybody at the table
or yourself early in the first round
last night
um look
you know um i i the the treylands pick
was what everybody on the table thought
that niners should do um as
uh regular consumers of this show will
know
i mean you posted the video last night
chris because yeah
i'll share along you had it i mean you
had it yeah well i texted you before and
i'm like if it's lance you gotta pop
that video up there
you gotta mic drop this thing what was
it what was it was uh
april 21st 21st last week yeah
so that's when i began hearing you know
this could be lance and it's
maybe even been lance all along and
that's what you know
uh kyle shanahan said last night now you
would know if you knew
that's what the niners would say about
the pick once they made it they're not
gonna sit there and go well yeah it was
we traded up for somebody else but this
guy was just so much better the last
couple weeks you know i i
it's it that wasn't a surprise to
to anybody i don't think uh on the set
other than the fact that you know the
bears trading up for justin fields was a
surprise
uh the raiders choice of alex
leatherwood um
that's the only player outside of out of
daniel jeremiah's top 50 that got
drafted last night
um so the raiders choosing who they
chose was definitely a head scratcher
for a lot of people in that draft hall
um but the biggest surprise of the day
quite honestly is you know what happened
i think
after we hung up yesterday and yeah the
report that scepter put out there that
that ian rappaport also added on to that
that aaron rodgers was telling people
that he had no intention of showing back
up in a packer uniform again
and that was the shocker of the day
how much of the run down did you guys
get you guys have to toss
because of that news well i mean
certainly our pre-show
um we reconfigured things and
um you know that's you know that's
something to keep an eye on
for from now on um the concept of of
rogers being traded last night was i
think completely
ridiculous um it may have been close
i know what uh schlereth said it was
close to the broncos
but once i heard that you know um as a
possibility
um after the draft you know like i i
you know i'm off of twitter during the
draft on purpose because i don't
want to know what is coming that is part
of the broadcast
so i saw afterwards that um that that
mark
had said something about that and to be
honest with you that made no
sense to me because if this is about
the end game scenario
of aaron rodgers the career ending
scenario for aaron rodgers if that's
what this is essentially all about and
him wanting a contract in dollars and in
terms
that gives him the ability to script his
career ending
similar to what happened with brady and
jimmy garoppolo
right that it and that the only way that
this would lead to him
not finishing his career with green bay
is if he wants to play till he's 45
like tom um if that's what this
truly is all about then why in the hell
would he okay a trade
to patrick mahomes division
why why would that be a more acceptable
yeah you know what
um i i i want you know to just
um pitch at least for this coming year
following up the mvp
uh by by leaving the division with goff
and justin fields for
at the time dalton and
you know and and cousins yeah let me
just throw my hat
into the mahomes twice a year ring
that makes no sense to me zero
and to be able to pull off a trade of
rogers
on draft i could not imagine a more
trafficked everybody else's busy day
than draft day like you the trade of
rogers doesn't get pulled off
on draft day just because the ugliness
that's gone on behind the scenes has
been revealed publicly that's just
none of it made sense to me the the the
thing that made sense to me
would have made sense to me is if there
were there was a trade with the the
broncos for jordan love
that would have made sense to me that
okay
this thing became ugly and we're you
know what it's
we're done we're gonna give the contract
up and george uncle
we made that wrong choice last year
jordan loves gone
rogers has proved he clearly is at the
top of his game for many more years to
come
jordan's gone he's officially jimmy g
now
he shows up to denver denver gets their
quarterback of the future
and the bro the packers get to choose
patrick zertan
as opposed to the corner that they
eventually took anyway
and whatever would come with jordan love
as well
you know what would would would um
would would green bay also get um
would would they have to give up another
two because jordan love is pretty damn
good would it would there be any more of
a transaction
right than just the first overall pick
that the
packers by pissing off rogers turned
uh 26 overall in 2020 into an eighth
overall in 2021 in the form of one of
the top corners that tj wanted
you know for the cowboys so that would
have been more
feasible to me than rogers getting dealt
last night
is this is this just the same type of
thing that we've seen all off season the
smoke the russell wilson smoke the
sean watson smoke the is it just it's
it's an uncomfortability because aaron
rodgers doesn't feel appreciated and the
packers are simply not going to move off
this or
i don't know none of us really know i
mean we're all wildly speculating right
right i mean absolutely last every last
one of us i mean
uh uh i i i don't know i i mean i'm not
there
at the granular level i mean i i don't
know
if the packers you know refused to meet
you know aaron and then reluctantly flew
out or they immediately flew out and
rogers
let them cool in their heels i mean
again these are
or or it's just been a normal like let's
talk and then
they just refuse to meet aaron's terms
in a manner that they felt that rogers
wanted again these are these are
everything i just said is all either
wildly speculative
or you know educated guesses we have
no earthly idea none did they
maybe not send a note you know
congratulating aaron on his engagement
you know what i mean like who the hell
knows about a personal relationship
between two business partners which is
really what it is
um i have no idea
at all what's going on between the two
of them none of us have either
uh rogers all year long was totally
kumbaya
about everything won an mvp
and then saw a guy who after 20 years
of a relationship football wise comes
into his house
with his new team that's been all in
built
for the remaining window of his career a
quarterback
career and beats rogers in a game
in which rogers is removed from the
field on fourth and goal
for a field goal like i don't know if
that's got something to do with it
i mean all of these all this whole the
whole narrative starting quarterback
in 2021 ryan i i feel like that too
i feel like if there is a guy that
actually has the power or leverage to
say hey you know what
you know what good luck you know you
guys you guys haven't helped me
i'm not going to help you through this
process i'm going to go i'm going to go
live my life
yeah and i can do it uh it's it's there
i got to tell you ryan this week we said
on the show
um chris and tj right i mean i i
i talked with you guys about it a couple
weeks ago and
i've told the viewers and listeners of
this show over and over again
the the news when a quarterback
restructures his contract
is dog bites man story the news of
quarterback
refusing to restructure his contract is
man bites dog that's the one where you
got to go
well something's up here because all
contracts are negotiated between
quarterback
and team to know well at this point in
time we're going to come to you and
go restructure and whatever but when
roger said no
that's when it's just like huh okay
what's up with that when my home says
okay i'll restructure my contract that's
like well
they probably planned that two years ago
yeah you know so
again it's going to come down to it
certainly now that the first round has
been you know
handled that for rogers to be traded it
is going to take a much
longer time than just a couple of hours
after
schefter dropped something on a draft
night
when there's i mean could you imagine
you're the denver gm
right yeah having to make their choices
and then this is happening
in their in their in their purview yeah
yeah and they're talking about do we get
justin fields can we get trey lance is
it possible what if mac jones is there
what if shirts hands there
they probably have 15 trades that
they've already talked about with 15
other partners that they've already
talked about
and all of a sudden they turn on the tv
and it's public what no doubt
everybody's not
known behind the scenes honestly but the
report that tom pelicero put out
yesterday
i think it was yesterday it all blends
together i know i think it's tom was on
with you guys yesterday
that um the niners called
the packers saying do you want three
overall for rogers
yep and and the initial response is like
oh
so the niners traded all that to go up
to three
to grind tape for a month only to come
up with the concept of
well we got to go yolo on rogers because
we don't really believe in these guys
to after that report going well no
kidding they're calling up about rogers
if you've heard about all this stuff
and you have to do that but they love
trey lansin for good reason
so you know put it all together could
you imagine you're denver and you're
doing all this stuff and then all of a
sudden it's just like
well we gotta call green bay we get we
gotta we got
all of that we gotta vet this thing out
a little bit here make sure
we're doing the right thing but that's
why i'm saying to me
the the plot the possibility would have
been
the packers calling uncle on everything
and trading jordan love
because you can't trade rogers for the
ninth overall selection in a draft what
are you kidding me
you couldn't even do it for three
because you're not
trying to acquire a quarterback right
you already got your quarterback that's
the reason why rogers is available
so the fix is get rid of the other
quarterback
sign rogers get a draft choice that's in
top 10 to actually supplement rogers
or the team while rogers is happy
in the remaining window of opportunity
that's what i
my ears were appealed for last night but
instead um but
instead they don't do anything and they
take a cornerback out of georgia that
wasn't nearly
wasn't really considered to be well i
don't know i mean like look i mean who
knows man
because that's the other problem and i
mentioned this on the draft last night
is like that was part of the problem of
the jordan love pick
is like okay so you're not going to give
offensive help to rogers
at least give him the defensive help
after the niners torched you in the nfc
championship game they didn't even do
that no then they go
and then they go get aj dylan in round
two and you're like oh i mean it's just
what are we doing let's see what dylan
looks like this year but at any rate
that was really
um intense last night tj you've got to
be
psyched about the way the cowboys
handled their business
last night oh he's been he's been
ecstatic i'm happy rich you know and i'm
even more happy because the day before i
predicted that we would take
my comparisons and you know in a
roundabout way i did predict that
um okay we're very happy
it was very like that was very mdt like
right there
but yeah i mean he great great pickup
but rich i do have a question for you
you know i've sat here for weeks and
asked you how you were feeling
you know we always kind of thought that
zack wilson would be the jets pick
now that we know and it did in fact
happen
how are you feeling well look i'm gonna
do a couple of favors for all of you
number one uh i know we're up against
the end of the hour
so i this is not a two-minute answer
you'll save this for monday you'll save
this one for monday i'm gonna i'm gonna
save that
large breadcrumb for monday we'll put a
pen in that one the jets did not yes the
jets did not
uh stand pat and get
naji harris who went to pick after the
jets
would have picked by the way they didn't
get travis etienne
who that was another thing last night
about the amazing first that we saw
the quarterback running back combination
from the same school
chosen in the first round by the same
team for the first time ever we've never
seen that before um
it's a trade-up to get a guard um put it
all together and i'll give my thoughts
on the jets
on monday daniel jeremiah is um
first up he's already booked for monday
we've got a lot of
other fun things in store because it's
just going to be tonight's going to be
great and then tomorrow with the run
rich run reveal we're excited about that
um nfl.com run rich run for everybody to
give
you can go to the nfl auction website um
just
go to google nfl auction go to the
website all the
cleats of all the uh of all the nfl
legends are autographed and the box as
well
um autographed i know these shoehonks
that are in the room right now
if you want to go and donate the box is
important rich it's important to have
the box
signed pair of you know uh ray lewis
cleats or rodwoods and cleats that's all
out there
um that reveal is saturday we'll talk
about it all on
on monday but i do have two cents on
that and then i cannot wait
to not wait to talk on monday
about the years to come of the jet
patriot battles between mack jones and
zach wilson
all right now wait for it it's going to
be great
all i have to say about that is i'm so
happy
it's not zach wilson versus trey lance
i'm just going to leave it at that
all right all right i i i'm i'm
i told chris brockman to be very excited
so
rich thank you again for uh for joining
us
and again for giving me this platform as
always enjoy tonight
you're doing a heck of a job rich eisen
everybody have a great show
thanks guys and and thanks to everybody
too you too tj
and um chris and and
um mike hoskins and and sean mitchell at
home
what you guys did on our social media at
rich eisen show last night to follow
along with the draft
was great i was thrilled to see that
once i got back to the hotel room
it's a lot of fun fired up thanks guys
thank you rich appreciate it all right
have a great night rich eisen everybody
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here